because deeply like you could have found  nothing and you almost felt like Colombo  you're like yeah you got that you got  that energy you're here now now what now  what like we're gonna do now and the  thing is if you find something if you do  look and you find something don't just  nag them like leaving it do something  yeah just you know I mean you wanna you  wanna keep the person around and then  just punish them I think modern women I  think they like being cheated on I swear  to God because the amount of girls that  come out yeah yeah because they never  yeah but then you could say about Modern  Men because they like the baddest [ __ ]  I mean I don't see it's interesting